there's been an explosion at a mosque in
the afghan capital kabul authorities
there say at least 10 people have been
killed let's talk to our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey who's in
kabul now stu what do we know about this
particular incident
yeah it's it's it's obviously quite a
big attack it happened about evening
prayers local people say it was a
suicide bomber who killed uh the imam
we're not sure how many people have been
killed one hospital says at least 27
people including five children had been
admitted to hospital and the numbers of
people dead we're hearing ranges from 10
to 50 it could be higher
it could be lower nobody's claimed
responsibility at the moment it's been
condemned by the taliban
i would say islamic state have been
carrying out attacks here
over the last few weeks or so
and so the suspicion is that it is they
who have carried out uh this attack
it's difficult to go up to the scene of
the uh the crime because the taliban
don't allow it and they're not very good
at giving information so we'll probably
get more uh tomorrow as i say they have
condemned this but it's interesting
isn't it you know they took over a year
ago
this there is no war taking place at the
moment but it still remains a very
dangerous city a very dangerous country
for that matter very much on a war
footing and only the other day we were
out and the taliban shoot us away uh
from one area because of a suspected
suicide bomb attack that was about to
happen so it's it's very tense here
still
they may have been celebrating the other
day a year of taking over but things
haven't changed that much in that year
okay stuart thank you very much